[Musique]
imaginez un instant le cauchemar de voir
certaines de vos informations
personnelles dévoilées au grand jour sur
le web sans votre consentement et tout
ça dans le but de vous nuire numéro de
téléphone adresse mot de passe
informations très intime tout y passe et
il ne s'agit pas nécessairement
d'informations obtenus par des moyens
illégaux
cette forme de divulgation non consenti
de harcèlement en ligne a été appelée
boxing
ce phénomène issu d'abord de forums de
discussion en ligne un peu plus
marginaux tels que forza n'aurait dit
mais qui s'est répandue ensuite partout
à l'ensemble du web via notamment
vous l'aurez deviné les réseaux sociaux
alors pourquoi faire du dock singh
plusieurs scénarios sont possibles
par pure vengeance personnelle pour se
faire justice à soi même ou un groupe
auquel on appartient pour soutenir une
cause ou en dénigrer une autre les
victimes de daxing ce compte
annuellement par milliers et parfois
cette pratique peut mener à des
dérapages qui n'épargne pas des
innocents vous souvenez des
manifestations de groupes suprémacistes
blancs en 2017 dans les rues de trois
villes et bonne grosse vague de daxing à
suivre
[Musique]
quatre coins des états unis des
internautes anti racistes se sont mis à
visionner des images des manifestants
suprémacistes dans le but de les
identifier pour ensuite divulguer des
informations personnelles à leur sujet
quant au queen un professeur des
génériques sans histoire de l'arkansas a
été identifié par erreur comme étant un
manifestants d'extrême droite
tout ça à cause d'une vague ressemblance
avec ce manifestant qui portait un
chandail du même département dans la
même université
résultat les données personnelles de
cancun ont été abondamment diffusée sur
le web
harcelé de toutes parts craignant pour
sa propre sécurité
il a dû se réfugier momentanément chez
des amis heureusement pour contrer le
dock singh les géants du web commencent
à réagir en 2016 facebook a modifié son
système pour favoriser des contenus
positif et des chercheurs travaillent
d'arrache-pied pour concevoir un outil
capable de détecter rapidement les cas
de daxing